President Trump says the partial
government shutdown will not end until
Democrats agree to put up billions for
his border wall a large part of the
federal government is still closed the
president is also backing his Treasury
Secretary after he caused more
uncertainty on Wall Street chip Reid is
at the White House chip
good morning well good morning you know
about 800,000 federal employees who
thought they'd be going back to work
today after the Christmas holidays will
either be furloughed or have to go back
to work without pay and nine federal
agencies are putting together
contingency plans for what's being
called an indefinite closure I can't
tell you where the government's gonna be
open after wishing merry Christmas to
troops from the Oval Office
president Trump vowed to keep the
government closed until he gets more
money for his wall I can tell you it's
not gonna be open until we have a wall
offense whatever they'd like to call it
he claimed workers affected by the
partial shutdown want him to fight for
the wall many of those workers have said
to me and communicated stay out until
you get the funding for the wall but
many of those federal workers sounded
off on Twitter saying they want to
return to work and get paid the
president is locked in a bitter
stalemate with Democratic lawmakers who
have said they will not support any
money for a wall in a joint statement
Democratic congressional leaders Chuck
Schumer and Nancy Pelosi wrote the
president wanted the shutdown but he
seems not to know how to get himself out
of it and while the president in a
flurry of tweets said he was waiting for
Democrats to make a deal
stock markets went on a Christmas Eve
free fall the president blamed the
Federal Reserve calling it the only
problem our economy has but he expressed
support for his Treasury secretary
Stephen minutia
who attempted to intervene in the stock
market struggles by calling the heads of
US banks over the weekend
very talented a very smart person the
White House says the partial shutdown
could continue into the new Congress
which begins January 3rd that's the day
Nancy Pelosi is expected to be sworn in
as the new Democratic Speaker of the
House Adriana
chip with Congress reconvening tomorrow
what is next for negotiations
well hatela it is simply a standoff at
this point the White House says the ball
is in the Democrats Court the Democrats
say no it's your move
but one Democratic source on Capitol
Hill did tell CBS News that the White
House offered 2.1 billion dollars for
border security plus four hundred
million dollars for president Trump's
quote other immigration priorities but
Democrats have called that a slush fund
now Nancy Pelosi has said she expects
that what will happen here is that when
she is the speaker they will quickly
pass a piece of legislation in the house
to reopen the government but it will not
contain any money for the wall so
there's certainly no guarantee that
President Trump would sign that Adriana
all right Jeffrey thank you